dozens thousands millions
behind the numbers used to describe what
is happening
are the people living this war
those fighting it those fleeing it
this is the picture of displacement in
ukraine
the russian invasion has devastated city
after city
this family left
in the donetsk region after seeing their
neighbors killed
my advice to those who are still back
home
leave while they haven't flattened
everything
there was nothing no gas no light no
water and no food because all the shops
have been ruined already it's impossible
to live there
the leve central train station is the
last major hub for refugees from the war
escaping to europe
air raid sirens here pale in comparison
perhaps to the violence they've left
behind
[Music]
victor and rosa are from a village near
kharkiv under russian occupation
after hiding in their basement for two
weeks
they found someone to smuggle them out
just before the russians closed the
checkposts
they say it was like living in a cage
we want the world to hear us it is a
free country no one was hurt here before
for me personally i lived with a man he
is a christian and i'm a muslim and we
live happily everything was great and in
one moment it ended
please stop the war
far from the fighting but not far enough
yet
one person on the platform told us
there's an easy way to tell where the
train is going if it's full of men
that's a domestic journey if it's full
of women and children those are the only
ones that are allowed to leave the
country
trains leaving this station are pulling
on
a chance to rest to recharge
a brief moment of calm
before the chaos of getting to the
border
and getting out of ukraine